things were so bad that I had to fly up
to New York and meet with rating
agencies before being sworn in to avoid
a guaranteed downgrade to junk status we
should have been America's grease
let me tell you the recent foundation
certainly makes me feel right at home
and i truly mean it and i'm glad and
honored that you are holding this
meeting here in San Juan and I am
grateful for the work you all do but
most importantly for the principles you
stand for my friend Grover Norquist has
said and I quote to understand where
America will be in 10 years read recent
today and i whole heartily agree and
that makes me optimistic about the
future of our nation one is an issue
after issue the people are coming around
to common sense solutions that are at
the very core of reasons mission that is
certainly the case in Puerto Rico and in
an increasing number of states led by my
fellow governors so it is that this
recent weekend 2012 takes place in an
exciting context and at what I see as a
promising juncture I am the eternal
optimist it is an exciting context in
the because here we are in Puerto Rico
god works in mysterious ways as my
grandma used to say who would have
thought that this territory of the
United States would come so far so fast
in turning the tide of big government
and unleashing the power of the free
market and individual freedom in just
three short years and that's the story I
want to share with you all tonight it is
a story that starts with what just three
years and one month ago was a deepest
recession and worse fiscal situation in
our nation in fact when I took office
our deficit stood at 3.3 billion dollars
representing forty-four percent of
revenues proportionally speaking it was
the highest in the nation worse than
recents homeland of California
I have to say that I'm sorry
out of the 50 and actually your governor
hasn't called me to take some notes on
what we're doing here anyhow out of the
50 states out of the 50 states in Puerto
Rico we were dead last the 51st in the
51st position at that time actually
things were so bad that I had to fly up
to New York and meet with rating
agencies before being sworn in to avoid
a guaranteed downgrade to junk status we
should have been America's grease
actually was so bad we didn't have
enough money to meet our first payroll
we have to take out a loan I must say my
wife asked me we could ask for a recount
on the on the votes it didn't work out
today as we speak our deficit is down to
just over six hundred million dollars or
seven percent of revenues in
proportional terms thirty-six states
currently have higher deficits than
puerto rico we are ranked number 15 and
we're closing in very quickly so what
have we been doing like a lot of
like-minded governors we have been right
sizing our garment and reining in
spending and when we say reining in
spending and cutting spending it's real
cuts not Washington cuts we really don't
have a choice because unlike the federal
government we don't print money at the
state level in my case as you owe men as
you've Tom mentioned I started by
cutting my own salary much to this
degree of my wife cutting the cabinet
members salaries much agree of their
spouses and eliminating thirty percent
of all the political appointee positions
between voluntary and mandatory
reductions in the workforce we shrunk
our garbage force by more than 21,000 in
the first year and actually in the first
three years we just got our numbers of
this administration we have reduced the
number of our employees by more than
36,000 that's also bored proportionately
than any state of the union and in
absolute numbers by I believe any state
in the Union and if the moon were to
become a state as well also in the moon
I think we're clear so about 8,000 of
them in the year one left voluntarily
they retired early government payroll is
now down by about a billion dollars a
year overall government spending is down
by more than 15 actually close to twenty
percent at the same time we began
enacting pro-growth policies to energize
the private sector because at the end of
the day a sustainable recovery whether
at the state or national level needs a
combination it needs both fiscal
responsibility and pro-growth policies
policies like the p3 program david
alvarez discussed this morning and which
led to what happened last year I hope
you enjoy David's presentation in 2011
the largest single infrastructure
investment in the nation was our 1.5
billion dollar toll road concession and
I'll get back to that and the pro-growth
policy side in a moment like many states
were also tackling the challenge of
funding our retirement system on the
positive side were among the few
jurisdictions on the American flag that
already eliminated defined benefit plans
so we have eliminated the risk of
widening act oriole deficits this past
this past three years we also took the
steps necessary to improve liquidity and
extend the life of the central
government's retirement system assets by
almost 8 years our record speaks for
itself and we are more determined than
ever to look leave up to our moto which
is Puerto Rico does it better our
progress on the fiscal side in addition
to promising progress on the economic
side as a result of smart pro-growth
policy has led to positive evoque
evaluations by the rating agencies of
the kind poor Rico had not seen in
decades almost almost 27 years between
2001 and 2007 because of mismanagement
and the nonstop erosion of the garments
fiscal situation Standard & Poor's alone
took six consecutive negative negative
actions against Puerto Rico's credit in
2000 April of 2010 Moody's acknowledged
the success of our fiscal stabilization
plan when it upgraded Puerto Rico's
credit rating from the level right
before junk 2 a 3 a bigger improvement
than any other state or territory we
also got our first positive outlook from
a credit rating agency nearly three
decades those positive ratings actions
took into account physical progress but
also our new direction on our overall
economic front a direction very much in
tune with the values are shared and
championed by the recent foundation
because all the while we have been
putting our fiscal house in order we've
also been changing the course of our
future Puerto Rico's pro-growth economic
reform program has entailed a series of
key public policy reforms to kick it off
given our limited public investment
capacity we passed the most advanced
public-private partnership glow in the
nation through our p3 program we're
moving forward about 3.5 billion dollars
in infrastructure projects
our first 33 in 2010 was to get our
public schools into the 21st century
we're investing over eight hundred and
seventy eight million dollars in a
school modernization program that also
goes head in hand with curricular reform
and by the way I appreciate the work the
recent foundation is doing on school
choice thank you I believe in choice for
sure and I speak as a parent as a father
for sure parents have a better
understanding of what is best for their
kids up until last year here in Puerto
Rico we had a state supreme court that
stood in the way of it but in the last
three years I've had the opportunity to
a point a majority of justices to our
state Supreme Court and all of those
justices favor school choice it just
happens that that testament school
choice is a major reason why we can be
optimistic about our future and I intend
to do a lot more about it now that i
have justices to back it up puerto rico
also completed permitting reform instead
of going to 21 different agencies
businesses can now go to just one single
permits office to get their endorsements
or better off just get online on POF
another major driving reporter because
rebound is tax reform as a territory
Puerto Rico has a mirror code to the
Internal Revenue Code just over a year
ago we enacted the biggest task tax
reform in our islands history as a
result the top corporate tax rate
immediately dropped from forty-one
percent to thirty percent they previous
seven tier corporate bracket was
simplified into three lower rates twenty
twenty-five and thirty percent and
starting in 2014 we will have just two
brackets 20 and 25 so that means our top
corporate tax rate will be twenty-five
percent
for and by the way in the meantime we
have dramatically simplified or in our
filing you know our tax returns and so
it will be a lot easier to file our tax
returns this year for individuals we
have reduced tax rates an average of
twenty-five percent over the next five
years that reduction is set to increase
to nearly fifty percent it will be a
sliding scale but those reductions are
tied by law to stain on our two-lane
road of fiscal responsibility and
pro-growth policies we've made our
taxpayers the guardians of fiscal
responsibility and pro-growth policies
in other words individual tax reductions
for the years 2014 through 2016 are
contingent on the Garmin meeting
targeted goals in operating expenses
revenues and economic growth I want the
taxpayers to keep us you know in check
in addition one percent of the islands
budget in 2014 and one and a half
percent 2015 2016 will be deposited into
a fiscal reserve one this reform
significantly improves Puerto Rico
competitiveness it has improved Puerto
Rico 15 positions in its global tax
ranking to further spur investment last
fall we also launched the best housing
marketing centers in the country they
are available to residents and
non-residents alike so you want to stay
around and
feel free and they are available up
until December of this year the
incentives includes no property taxes
for five years for new residential
properties purchased during this special
window in addition to no capital gains
tax obligation with no expiration date
and by the way the elimination of the
capital gains tax was made permanent in
a later bill and purchases of existing
properties actually benefit from a
50-percent exemption on capital gains
for those who may buy either a new or
existing property to rent during that
time frame you're also eligible for zero
tax obligation for for 10 years on net
rental income consider what has been
considered what has been happening in
the residential real estate market in
the country as a whole compared to
Puerto Rico between time we enacted
those intent is in September of 2010 and
November last year new home sales on the
island jumped sixty percent in the
country as a whole new home sales were
down six percent during the same period
of time by same token existing home
sales on the island grew by twenty six
and a half percent while overall US
growth was an anemic one-point-eight
percent our latest economic measures are
also designed to reverse population
decline that Puerto Rico experienced in
the last decade this year we have put
into place laws that promote residency
and attract capital for qualified
investors and individuals we're
providing a four percent income tax rate
during a twenty year period with a
special tax decree as well as extensions
on tax payments on interest and evidence
these on top of the entrepreneurship
incentives we have already put in place
for current residents Porto Rico is on
the rebound and entering a new era of
sustainable growth for the first time
since 2007 total employment is up and
the unemployment rate is moving in the
right direction down by two full
percentage points compared with the
previous year in December employment in
the private sector experienced its
biggest increase in nearly five years
last year more than 14,000 new
corporations were created the highest
rate of new company development in our
history our rebound has also been
recognized by the world economic forum
in global competitiveness among 142
jurisdictions around the world Puerto
Rico claim last year from the position
41 to 35 we have indeed changed the
course of Puerto Rico future we will not
stop until we get the job done that
includes tackling the fundamental issue
of the islands ultimate political status
destiny territorial status for a land
and population of American citizens
natural-born American citizens of the
size of this size was never meant to go
on and on and on with no desolation in
sight that's not what the founding
fathers intended to see happening and
the only ultimate destination consistent
within citizens of this great nation of
ours is stated but that's for the people
to decide and they will do so this
November on Election Day in addition to
deciding whether we want to continue to
move our rebound forward or go back to
the failed policies of the past boaters
here will also choose whether or not
they want to maintain the islands
current status as a territory more
irrespective of whether a majority of
Puerto Ricans want to change territorial
status or not it's also important in
high time that voters express the
preference for ultimate destination
there are three stay hood independence
or a pact of free association between so
two sovereign nations the outcome of the
boat will be decisive in changing the
course for the future you all know I
believe what my preference is I think if
we have been good enough to fought side
by side in the trenches in every single
war in the last century and this entry
by a way oftentimes in greater numbers
at most states to give you an idea since
911 we have contributed over 21,000 men
and women in uniform to the global war
on terror our number is greater than 45
states so if if we are good enough to be
in the trenches we're also good enough
to fully participate in the
decision-making process in America and
when we come to the table as equals I am
convinced we will have much to
contribute and reach our nation I look
forward to forging that future together
and I thank you for choosing Puerto Rico
as your location for this year's
conference since I mentioned school
choice tell me if we could come over
here i have a proclamation commemorating
school choice week in Puerto Rico which
is a signal of things to come down here
and I want to give you this Proclamation
and hopefully the next time we see each
other will be well on our way to
implement school choice fully in Puerto
Rico thank you thank you thank you my
pleasure thank you thank you hi governor
for to know President Obama has also
been in office for three years yes I
know has my question is has he asked you
for any advice along the way I don't
think so
he came down last summer actually and I
raised the number of issues are
affecting us to begin with same way that
a lot of people demand that our border
be protected in the southwestern part of
the nation I asked that our border be
protected here as well and and he he
simply did not react to that at all and
I also raised issues that I have with
EPA and the way it's killing jobs in
Puerto Rico and all across America
governor you you've done the heroic
thing and making the cuts but are you
winning the hearts and minds and I asked
this in the context of we talked about a
year and a half ago and you said your
advice to other politicians is to do it
like a band-aid do make the cuts quickly
and like Ronald Reagan and others
eventually the public would see the
benefit and come around and so we
research that and we found Ronald Reagan
and one state governor and we couldn't
find many others and are you popular as
let me tell you i'll give you my numbers
i'll be happy to share my numbers with
you a year ago I was not electable
actually I was not presentable back in
November all polls had me tied with my
contender and we have recent numbers for
a few weeks ago and I would win a race
here so and we're still you know some
some months away from the election I am
convinced we're going to win we have
closed that gap it was about it at 20
plus percent gap again by last November
it was again a virtual tie and by now
I'm ahead and we have our momentum with
us to give you an example on the
economic front home sales are up as I
mentioned car sales are off retail sales
are up cement sales are up and for the
first time in six years employment
numbers move into positive territory but
then again I'm I work hard the next for
the next ten months but if if I
word you know to have an election today
I would win so it's dual
you mentioned the destination where
you're heading the top 1% earners as so
many of us that are leaving the United
States there's so many people in state
legislators that are looking and talking
there's talks on how to disconnect and
secede from the union why in god's name
in would you want to join this place and
by being independent which is your other
option I think this would it would be
such a magnet to all those very wealthy
people that are leaving to come here
they don't want to come here because
it's a territory well let me tell you we
are natural-born American citizens as I
mentioned and we're proud of that and
we're proud of the service of so many
thousands and thousands of our young men
and women in uniform for our nation and
I again I'm an optimist otherwise I will
not be holding this job and I truly
believe that things have to get worse to
get better I am convinced we are the
positions are ripe for major
transformations at the national level
and and I'm hopeful that I'll be we
don't one among many governors at the
state level that will be assisting in
making sure that it happens in
Washington that transformation has to
take Mei Mei fashions I'll tell you
about about here because here for
example with a certain state legislature
it's been very difficult at times to
stay the course of fiscal responsibility
even though we have a clear majority and
they have been supportive but it is it
is tough you know I I have a pen that i
use for vetoes and i use it often one
thing we're doing is since we are
shrinking the size of the executive
branch if the voters agree with what i
suggested
and and and actually was approved by the
state legislature we would shrink the
size of our state legislature by thirty
percent this August August nineteenth I
believe we will actually the voters will
have a chance to determine if they also
want to shrink the size of the state
legislature I believe it's going to be
an 82 to issue and I believe it's going
to be a clear majority in favor of
amending our Constitution the state
constitution to actually reduce the size
of our state legislature I still believe
common sense can be actually saved from
the hands of those in power and that the
boaters generally speaking earlier
sooner or later they will be able to
take control of their lives and and
control that government so again we are
American citizens we're proud of that I
have over 2,000 veterans here how can I
just you know tell them that you know
let's walk away from our history plus
independence is favored right two and a
half percent so in Alaska there's a
stronger pro-independence movement than
here it's double digits really so what
we want to do is we want to be part of
that revolution that I'm convinced will
occur and will change Washington